but before we leave it I have to tell a
wonderful story about the telescope
which relates to what we've been talking
about new telescope seems to be a good
metaphor for psychedelics when Galileo
discovered the telescope he was not
immediately slapped down by the church
it took a few months for them to even
sort out what the issue was here and
then of course eventually he had to
recant but in the year preceding his
trial
Galileo was of course before the
invention of the telescope well-known in
influential circles in Rome as an
inventor and an scientist natural
scientist so in his apartment on the on
the rooftop he set up his telescope and
would hold small garden parties for
influential Roman citizens among them
great Cardinals and princes of the
church who were involved in deciding the
issue of whether or not he was dabbling
in heretical material so one evening he
had Cardinal Runkle
Roncalli of the Holy Office which is the
the keepers of the Doctrine of the Faith
and had him to dinner and said
excellency would you care to look
through my telescope and the Cardinal
aloud is how he would like to look
through the telescope and so Galileo
pointed it at the full moon which was
rising over the city and the Cardinal
peered into the telescope and Galileo
said and so excellent see as you see
there appear to be oceans and range of
mountains on our
mr. world and the Cardinal looked for a
long time and and said yes but Senor
surely we can agree among ourselves that
this is only a hallucination well it
turns out they couldn't agree among
themselves that it was a hallucination
and I don't think that we can agree with
our establishment that what we perceive
is only a hallucination it is and yet it
isn't it is a true hallucination I
remember once in the Amazon very bizarre
incident I was lying with a fever in in
a hut and stomach some horrible thing
had happened to me anyway I was in a
terrible state and I heard these
children singing outside in Spanish and
the song that they were singing as I
slowly and painfully translated it I
could hardly believe my ears
the song was behold behold the final
illusion at last at last the final
illusion and this is I think from the
point of view of historical society what
we are looking at we are looking at the
final illusion the body of Eros expelled
from greece burned at hallucis driven
out of the european mind by busy and
pesky celibates
denied repressed cut apart lay in wait
in the mountains of the new world for
the european civilization that would
eventually conquer the new world and as
it burned and pillaged and raped its way
deeper into the interior of the new
months that it proposed to put under
European sway at last at last in 1953
Gordon wasps and glimpsed the final
illusion we have found we you remember I
said yesterday that the archetype of
Western society is the prodigal son the
wanderer who leaves his birthright who
leaves the comfort of the village and
the bride who was planned for him and
goes out and does something tremendous
and ambiguous and unimaginable and
returns with the gift difficult to
obtain returns with the healing plant
the magic word the jeweled crown and
lays it at the feet of the mother so
long parted from and by that act creates
a historical closure you'll recall at
the beginning of this weekend I talked
about the hexagram that had been thrown
for the fate of our planet work on what
has been spoiled through the line work
on what has been spoiled by the father
and what has been spoiled by the father
is the feminine and the planet as the
exterior manifestation of the feminine
leading to the change which is the
cauldron the alchemical vessel the
theatre and laboratory of the witch's
magic the potion the transforms and in
the act of transforming nature through
cooking in the act of transforming human
nature through the cooking
of the historical process we have made
ourselves unrecognizable to our
ancestors even as we shall be
unrecognizable to our children but
ladies and gentlemen this souffle is
done this pie is cooked it's time to
take it out of the oven
give the oven a rest and spread the
board you know with the passing of the
patriarchy I I recall that wonderful
line in Finnegan's Wake where Joyce says
grandpa bus has fallen down but grinny
sprigs of the board sunny-side up with
care if you want to be parked if you
want to be Phoenix to come and be parked
because up Nant prospector you're going
to sprout all your worth and whoop your
wings and so that's what I invite you to
do to what fear Wayne will soon
woof woof
[Music]
you